[Musik]
Waffen Sanktionen Allianzen die Ukraine
kämpft um ihre Zukunft das ist unser
Thema heute abend 22 Uhr haben wir es
gut dass sie mit dabei sind liebe
Zuschauer Drohnen über dem Kreml
explodierende tanklage und jetzt ein
Angriff jenseits der Grenze die Ukraine
trägt den Krieg nach Russland Ziel
bleibt die Rückeroberung der russisch
besetzten Gebiete auch der Krippe dabei
sollen Raketen und bald auch Kampfjets
aus dem Westen helfen aber entscheidet
sich die Zukunft des Landes entscheidet
sich die Zukunft der Ukraine allein auf
dem Schlachtfeld die USA und China
bestimmen mit über die Zukunft des
Landes mit welchen Interessen das fragen
wir uns und diese Gäste
die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses Marie Agnes
Strack zimmermann
Sigmar Gabriel Vorsitzender der
Atlantikbrücke
die Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken
Amira Mohammed Ali
der britische Wirtschaftshistoriker Adam
tous
und Carlo Marsala Militärexperte
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
und die begrüßt die Gäste dieser Sendung
nochmal ausgesprochen herzlich die
Gefechte um bachmut nehmen ab aber die
Kämpfe verlagern sich auf russisches
Territorium
Bilder der Zerstörung dieses Mal aus
Russland
belgorodna der Grenze
zwei freiwilligen Milizen attackieren
die Stadt sie sind Russen sagen sie
moskau sieht die Urheber woanders
am 22 Mai sind ukrainische Nationalisten
auf russisches Territorium eingedrungen
70 Terroristen wurden beseitigt
die Ukraine bestreitet jede Verwicklung
jenseits der Grenze präsentieren die
Milizen hinterher erbeutetes russisches
Kriegsgerät
in bachmut scheint die Schlacht
endgültig entschieden behauptet der
Wagner Chef
ab heute dem 25 Mai bis zum ersten Juni
ziehen wir unsere Einheiten aus bachmut
zurück und übergeben die Stellungen an
das reguläre russische Militär
der Westen macht unterdessen den Weg
frei für die Lieferung von Kampfjets an
die Ukraine
Washington gibt nach langem Zögern
grünes Licht
gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern beginnen
wir ukrainische Piloten auf Flugzeugen
der vierten Generation auszubilden
darunter auch die F16
der Angriff auf Belgorod könnte nicht
der letzte gewesen sein die Milizen
kündigen weitere Attacken an
das ist in der letzten Woche
zusammen zu fassen es geschieht genug
kallomasala ist bei uns von der
bundeswehruniversität in München Herrn
Angriffe auf russische Dörfer diese
Kampfjet Allianz tritt der Krieg in
ihren Augen in eine neue Phase
insofern in eine neue Phase als das
jetzt natürlich alle auf diese
ukrainische Offensive warten und
gleichzeitig glaube ich ist mit der
Kampfjet Allianz auch sehr klar dass man
seitens westlicher Staaten der Ukraine
jetzt alles wirklich zur Verfügung
stellen will auch wenn diese westlichen
Kampfjets in vier bis sechs Monaten erst
kommen was sie benötigt um entscheidende
Erfolge in dieser Gegend Offensive zu
haben also da ist schon gewisser Druck
drin der auch durch die internationale
Situation zu erklären ist also die
Amerikaner werden irgendwann in
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf reingehen da
wird es dann ruhiger werden mit der
Unterstützung der Ukraine von daher ist
hier sozusagen sehr stark jetzt dieser
dieses entscheidende Momentum und
deshalb werden auch so große Hoffnungen
in diese Offensive gesetzt wovor ich
waren würde ja also es wird keine
entscheidende Offensive sein die Ihnen
ein paar Tagen oder ein paar Wochen
Ergebnisse zeigt das wird eine lange
Offensive sein die kleine Ergebnisse
zeigen wird aber die Erwartung ist
momentan extrem hoch und man tut alles
um die Ukraine sozusagen dazu zu bewegen
diese Erwartungen zu erfüllen und jetzt
muss in diesem Zusammenhang auch
verstehen was da in Belgorod passiert
ist also auf russischem Territorium
passiert ist was weiß man über diese
angeblich russischen Kämpfer alles
handelt sich da wohl um zwei
Freiwilligen minizen die eine hat schon
mal vor ein paar Monaten allerdings
sozusagen ohne gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
versucht in Belgorod Unruhe zu stiften
sagen wir mal so die zweite meines
Wissens war eher bekannt das Internet
Phänomen und ist jetzt plötzlich ein
reales Phänomen ich glaube diese
Belgorod Geschichte fügt sich ein in das
was die Ukrainer jetzt seit Wochen
machen also sie bereiten das
Schlachtfeld vor dazu zählen halt
Angriffe auf russische sozusagen
Versorgungslinie dazu zählen die
Angriffe auf die Tank Dinger die
Munitionslager und sie stiften ganz
einfach Verwirrungen zeigt ganz einfach
Russland muss jetzt seine Grenze besser
schützen das heißt Kräfte werden zur
grenzensicherung gebunden also diese
Milizen sagen sie ganz eindeutig sind
Ukraine oder sind ukrainische
also man weiß es nicht ich gehe davon
aus dass es Russen sind aber letzten
Endes kommen sie ja von irgendwoher und
sie haben diese gepanzerten Fahrzeuge
die haben sie auch von irgendwoher genau
sagen ich vermute mal ohne genaues
Wissen zu haben die stehen da nicht
einfach irgendwo auf russischen
Territorium rum ja und inwieweit dann
Zusammenhang besteht zwischen denen und
dem ukrainischen Generalstab das vermag
keiner zu sagen aber faktum ist
die Russen haben Probleme mit ihrer
Grenzsicherung das wird deutlich das ist
genauso wie mit diesen Drohnen also wenn
sie wirklich wie gestern die New York
Times berichtet durch ukrainische
Spezialeinheiten abgeschickt worden sind
wir bei dem Kreml muss man noch mal
sagen
die Schwäche der russischen
Luftverteidigung die Schwäche des
russischen Geheimdienstes der sozusagen
nicht mitbekommt dass ich solche Kämpfer
auf seinem Boden aufhalten die auch noch
Drohnen dabei haben und hier wird
Verwirrung geschäftet also keiner machen
die bereiten die gegen Offensive vor
indem sie sozusagen shaping the
battlefield heißt das also Schlachtfeld
vorbereiten aber sie stiften auch
gleichzeitig Verwirrungen damit die
russischen Kräfte nicht wissen wo was
passieren wird und ständig irgendwo
gebunden sind oder sozusagen verstärken
muss mit Ali von der Linken ist bei uns
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Partei vom
Mohammed Ali ist das Recht der Ukraine
sich auch auf russischem Territorium
gegen diesen Angriff zu verteidigen
lassen schwierige Frage also die Ukraine
hat natürlich einen
Selbstverteidigungsrecht das ist ja gar
keine Frage sie werden von Russland
angegriffen aber ich meine die Menschen
die in Russland dann zu Tode kommen sind
ja nicht unmittelbar in diesen Angriff
verwickelt also das ist finde ich
problematisch sie finden problematisch
wenn man Zivilisten treffen momentan
trifft man ja eben in aller erster Linie
militärische Einrichtungen auf russische
Seite
das ist die Frage der Bewertung es sieht
man das zum Selbstverteidigung dazu oder
geht das darüber hinaus das ist ja die
entscheidende Frage da und das muss
völkerrechtlich geprüft werden egal
militärische Einrichtungen anzugreifen
ist völkerrechtliche egal ja aber wie
stellen Sie denn sicher dass dabei keine
Zivilisten zu tun die Frage der
völkerrechtlichen Prüfung angesprochen
militärische Einrichtungen auf dem
Territorium des Gegners anzugreifen ist
völkerrechtlich völlig legal es gibt
sogar völkerrechte die sagen den Kreml
anzugreifen weil vom Kreml wird dieser
Krieg aus sozusagen gesteuert ist auch
völkerrechtlich egal also das ist ganz
klar die Frage der Zivilisten ist eine
andere Frage aber diese Einrichtungen
anzugreifen da gibt's völkerrechtlich
überhaupt gar keine Streitigkeiten das
ist egal fragen wir vielleicht den
britischen
wirtschaftshistorikerweise heute auch
bei uns in der Sendung ist Tattoos sie
sind in Großbritannien geboren und
Lehren und Lernen und aufgewachsen aber
eben in den USA kolumbia University New
York die US-Amerikaner wollten
eigentlich immer aus fließen dass die
Ukraine auch russischem Boden erreichten
warum und wie erklären sie sich dass das
für die US-Amerikaner jetzt auch kein
Problem mehr ist ich weiß nicht ob man
so ohne weiteres sagen kann dass der
Angriff auf das Kreml für die Amerikaner
kein Problem darstellt und ich würde
diese diese Milizionäre die jetzt
Russland angegriffen haben in ein ganz
anderes Kiste tun ich meine soweit ich
weiß sind das rechtsradikale Hooligans
zum Teil die irgendwie ausgerüste unter
anderem auch mit deutschem Hintergrund
die die dort unter anderem auch ihre
Labels vertreten das sind ja das sind ja
wirklich unternehmerisch praktisch
unterwegs man denkt zurück an die an die
zöldner der der Früh Neuzeit zum Teil so
was was dort für eine Selbstdarstellung
stattfindet ich ich gebe ihn vollkommen
recht ich denke das wird von der vom
Tief aus vom Generalstab vermutlich
ausgenutzt aber der amerikanische
Perspektive da offiziell distanziert
sein davon entfernt sich Washington so
gut es geht und denken Sie dass es
riskant wäre und nicht nur Putin ein
Problem ist sondern da auch aus Sicht
der Amerikaner dann schon eine Grenze
überschritten würde
ich denke die Grenzüberschreitung durch
diese munitionäre wird niemand besonders
beunruhigen ich meine das ist der
nachher dort
ist ein bisschen peinlich und das wird
bestimmt ein Signal gewesen sein die
Ukrainer wenn Sie in diese Wagen
zur Verfügung gestellt haben werden sich
was dabei gedacht haben in anderen
Worten sie sind sehr offensichtlich
amerikanische Wirkung aber ich meine es
geht um die 16 im Moment das ist ein
viel entscheidender wir wollen ja nur
verstehen denn es ist eben ein
besonderes Ereignis marie-agner
Zimmermann ist bei uns Vorschlag
Zimmermann Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses des Deutschen
Bundestages noch muss man sagen unter
diesen Kämpfern sind eben darüber
sprachen wir gerade auch
Rechtsextremisten auch mit einem
bekannten deutschen Hintergrund an Sie
die Frage ist es eine gute Idee damit
ausgerechnet auch die miteinander Putins
dass der Nazis in Kiew sitzen im Grunde
noch mal mit zu befeuern nein das sehe
ich nicht so das ist ein Krieg hat ja
seine eigene Mechanismus Mechanismen und
als der Krieg begann als Russland den
Überfall startete waren ungefähr 200.000
Ukrainer unter Waffen heute sind es über
eine Million es sind also extrem viele
an die Front gerufen worden oder werden
sie nie ausschließen dass auch einige
dabei sind die keiner will keiner
braucht das ist die grausame Logik des
Krieges die sozusagen aus diesem
Entsetzen heraus agieren aber das ist
eine sehr enge Ansicht derer oder sehr
enge an sich derer die sich damit
täglich beschäftigen für die Menschen in
der Ukraine die seit 15 Monaten im Krieg
leben müssen
was ganz anderes und ich glaube was sehr
wichtig ist gerade weil das aufkam was
ist völkerrechtskonform und was das
völkerrechtswidrig nach wie vor ist
diese Angriff Russland die
völkerrechtswidrig sich zu wehren
völkerrechtskonform und wenn die Ukraine
versucht
Lieferketten sozusagen zu durchbrechen
dann ist das legitim denn sie wollen
natürlich verhindern dass erstmal der
Angriff startet und da bedeutet man
versucht man das eben im Vorfeld
ja zu unterbinden sieht man gabriel ist
uns zugeschaltet aus Goslar einen guten
Abend zu ihnen ehemalige
außenministervorsitzender der
Atlantikbrücke Herr Gabriel die Ukraine
traut sich mehr hat man das Gefühl die
Verbündeten Frauen sich mehr auch dieses
Gefühl kann man haben gibt es für einen
Erfolg der Ukraine mittlerweile keine
roten Linien mehr
die roten Linien sind ja eben zum Teil
beschrieben worden ist eine der roten
Linien ist das die Nato und auch die
Vereinigten Staaten auf gar keinen Fall
in einer direkte Konfrontation mit
Russland kommen wollen umgekehrt
übrigens Russland auch nicht mit den USA
oder der NATO die rote Linie gibt es
weiterhin ich glaube auch dass wir jetzt
gerade über Dinge geredet haben die
natürlich da hat er schon recht die
Russen verunsichern sollen aber dass das
vermutlich eher in Anführungsstrichen
tatsächlich neben Kriegsschauplätze sind
wahrscheinlich stehen wir vor der
schlimmsten Landschlacht seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg wir werden nach den
fürchterlichen Bildern und Erlebnissen
die die Ukraine jetzt schon hinter sich
hat noch viel schlimmere Bilder sehen
und ich befürchte dass mit lange dauern
das was wir jetzt gesehen haben ist
nicht das was als Offensive bezeichnet
wird das wird eine riesige Schlacht wir
reden über 30 40.000 Menschen auf der
ukrainischen Seite und
mindestens das gleiche auf der
russischen Seite das wird furchtbar im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und ich sehe
nicht
wie das verhindert werden könnte weil
beide Seiten diesen Krieg weiter wollen
weil die Ukraine auf gar keinen Fall
nachgeben wird übrigens die tatsächliche
Veränderung der Lage besteht natürlich
darin dass die Ukraine jetzt in die
Offensive geht und die Russen in der
Defensive sind Herr Masala wird darüber
mehr sagen können als ich es kann aber
das bedeutet auch dass ich das
Kräfteverhältnis ändern muss wenn man
gewinnen will und dass die Zahl der
Opfer auf der Seite der Ukraine auch
größer werden wird man darf sich nicht
Illusionen darüber machen was da jetzt
auf die Menschen zukommt
weil die Reaktionen Herr massaller nickt
zu dem was Sigmar Gabriel gerade sagte
weil die Reaktion der Russen noch
brutaler sein wird nein das ist nicht
der Punkt aber das ist das generelle
sozusagen dictum wer angreifen muss
immer eine Vielzahl von von Menschen
haben im Verhältnis zu dem der
verteidigt 3:1 sagt man ja 3:1 ist
klassisch man kann auch vier zu eins
sagen kommt auf das Terrain an aber drei
zu eins vier zu eins ist sozusagen so pi
mal Daumen die Regel der zweite Punkt
ist dass die Russen ja jetzt Monate
Langzeit gehabt haben ihre Verteidigung
Stellungen auszubauen so und wir sehen
durch Satellitenbilder sowohl im Norden
der Creme sowohl im Süden es sind also
eine britische Zeitung hat gesagt das
sind die Best ausgebautes und
Verteidigungsstellungen seit dem Ende
seit dem ersten weltkriegt mit drei
Ringen weil sie so viel Zeit hatten
genau wir haben Informationen von
ungefähr 30.000 Minen nicht Anti
Personen sondern Anti panzermien die da
irgendwie in den letzten Monaten
vergraben wurden also von daher es wird
kein Durchmarsch deswegen sage ich man
soll keine zu hohen Erwartungen haben
wie Ende Juli wo plötzlich eine gesamte
russische Front im Norden kollabierte
und die Ukrainer 50 oder 60 km
vorgestoßen sind genau an einem Tag
sondern das werden ich der einzige
Unterschied zu Herrn Gabriel das wird
keine Schlacht sondern das werden
Schlachten werden und die werden
langfristig sein die werden langwierig
sein und die werden natürlich blutig
sein ja das wird passieren
beide Seiten wollen den Krieg nicht
beenden da möchte ich doch gerne
reingehen also die Ukraine würde nichts
lieber als dass dieser Krieg zu Ende
geht denn es ist ihr Volk was
abgeschlachtet wird
Wladimir Putin kann heute seine Truppen
abziehen und dann ist der Krieg sofort
geändert aber so lange diese Offensive
eben läuft diese Angriff wehrt sich die
Ukraine werden
beschreibt die Lage richtig trotzdem ist
es so dass Kriege Enden ja in der Regel
auf zwei Weisen entweder einer gewinnt
und der andere verliert oder beide sind
müde und beides ist nicht der Fall weder
es werden wir einen klaren Gewinner und
einen klaren Verlierer sehen noch sind
beide erschöpft und das bedeutet dass
wir eher vor einer längeren bewaffneten
Auseinandersetzung stehen als das was
jetzt viele glauben dass es sozusagen
eine da hat er natürlich recht nicht es
wird nicht eine große Schlacht sein es
gibt auch nicht morgen Verhandlungen
weil eben beide Seiten ihre
strategischen Ziele weiter verfolgen wir
sind der festen Überzeugung dass die
Ukraine nicht nur formal völkerrechtlich
im Recht ist sondern auch politisch
jedes Recht hat sich zu verteidigen und
dass der Angreifer und der Täter in
Russland ist und nicht in der Ukraine
aber beide haben eben strategische Ziele
die sie verfolgen und diese
strategischen Ziele werden sie aufgeben
und das schlimme ist eben ist die
Erfahrung auch da keiner Masala
wahrscheinlich viel mehr zu sagen ist ja
dass es selten Kriege gibt die nach 15
Monaten enden und am Ende übrigens enden
die immer nicht auf dem Schlachtfeld es
gibt zwei Kriege die auf dem
Schlachtfeld geändert haben das war der
Verlust Deutschlands im Zweiten
Weltkrieg und der Verlust Japans die
Niederlage Japans im Pazifik ansonsten
sind kriege immer irgendwann an einem
langen Verhandlungsprozess beendet
worden und den kann ich nicht erkennen
dass der uns bevorsteht sondern uns
besteht erstmal bevor ganz viel schwerer
Auseinandersetzungen und viele viele
Tote von momentan und Scholz also auch
unser Bundeskanzler wird mittlerweile
entschiedener und entschlossener weil
sie gemerkt haben dass Putin eben auf
gar keinen Fall verhandlungsbereit ist
das ist die These sehen Sie denn
irgendwo bei Villa die mir Putin eine
Bereitschaft diesen Krieg zu beenden
die kann ich so nicht erkennen erzählt
macht er ja überhaupt keine keine
Aussagen in so eine Richtung dass er das
vorhat dennoch bin ich der Auffassung
dass man versuchen muss Wege zu finden
ihm dass du zu bewegen dass er die
Bereitschaft entwickelt einen
Verhandlungstisch zu gehen und ein
Waffenstillstand als erstes Mal
auszuverhandeln oder sich dazu bereit zu
erklären das wäre ja der erste
wünschenswerte Schritte mit der sterben
in der Ukraine endet und sie haben
natürlich recht Frau Zimmermann ähm wenn
Russland diesen Angriffskrieg beendet
dann ist er beendet das stimmt ja nur
ähm das tun sie ja nicht das ist ja
leider die Realität ich würde es mir
auch anders wünschen aber so ist es ja
das heißt man muss Wege finden er an den
Verhandlungstisch zu kommen und man
sieht ja in anderen Bereichen man sieht
bei den bei den Gefangenen ähm
austauschen man sieht bei dem
getreideabkommen das sind anderen
Bereichen ist möglich ist zumindest
kleine Verhandlungserfolge zu erreichen
und das haben wir gesehen dass es andere
Länder gibt Brasilien zum Beispiel auch
eine Zahl von von afrikanischen Ländern
die sagen wir möchten
hier und zusammenschließen und versuchen
eine friedensative zu starten und ich
glaube das ist ein eine gute Initiative
die man auch unterstützen sollte denn
auf militärischen Wege Druck auf
Russland auszuüben das ist ja der Weg
der jetzt gegangen wird ich denke es
wäre richtig so versuchen auch
wirtschaftlichen Wege Druck auf Russland
auszuüben denn die Sanktionspolitik hat
das ja nicht gesagt aber Russland ist es
auch ein Grund warum die
Sanktionspolitik des von Europa nicht
erreicht hat war ja das Russland sich
schon lange wirtschaftlich also sich
nicht schon lange aber sich inzwischen
wirtschaftlich unabhängiger gemacht von
der EU indem sie viel längere Verbindung
nach China Brasilien andere Länder haben
das heißt man muss doch versuchen mit
diesen Ländern einen Tisch zu kommen und
gemeinsam wirtschaftlich versuchen auf
Russland Druck aus aber sie müssten
ja dann auch etwas in die parkschale
werfen können versuchen wir vielleicht
beide Dinge erstmal zu ordnen Sanktionen
reden wir gleich ich würde gerne noch
mal nach der Möglichkeit Fragen Frau
Zimmermann parallel jetzt zu verhandeln
das ist eine sehr besondere Offensive
die da erwartet wird haben wir gerade
schon gesagt die wird nicht so
groß und mächtig und gewaltig sein wie
die des letzten Jahres und auch nicht so
erfolgreich hätte die Ukraine denn haben
sie überhaupt noch die Chance und auch
die Unterstützung des Westens nach
dieser Offensive noch weiterzumachen und
noch eine zweite zu machen und
durchzuhalten wie lange wird der Atem
naja was ist das was ist der Wunsch und
warum kämpfen die Ukraine so tapfer das
muss man ja sagen weil sie nicht
akzeptieren nachvollziehbar dass ihre
Integrität der Grenzen verletzt wird und
man muss immer daran erinnern dass nach
dem grausamen Zweiten Weltkrieg die
Vereinten Nationen gegründet wurden
damit eben nie wieder der größere der
Stärkere den schwächeren überfällt und
deswegen wird die Ukraine alles tun um
diese Integrität der Grenzen übrigens
auch der Krim wieder herzustellen und es
ist auch in unserem Interesse dass sie
da erfolgreich sind weil sonst wird das
nicht der letzte Krieg in diesem
Jahrhundert dort gewesen sein die
russische Armee wird sich erholen und
dann wird es wieder ein Versuch geben
das muss man einfach ganz nüchtern
betrachten und deswegen ist dieser Krieg
ja so dramatisch so blutig wirklich
schrecklich weil er eben ein Angriff auf
die freie westliche Welt ist ich frage
noch mal nach unserem Atem dem langen
Atem besondere Offensive er dem tust die
wird nicht so erfolgreich und so
gravierend sein wie die des letzten
Jahres wird sie überhaupt diesen Krieg
in irgendeiner Hinsicht entscheiden oder
sagen Sie auch nein das wird ein sehr
lange sehr grausamer Krieg sein und
bleiben ich glaube die Expertise sagt
sie wird sehr gravierend sein aber eben
nicht sehr erfolgsversprechend das ist
das Fatale also die Anstrengung muss
massiver sein als im letzten Jahr aber
die Erfolgs auch sich sind geringer
entscheidend ist das glaube ich vor
allem für die politische Unterstützung
in den Vereinigten Staaten wo gewisse
Weise die Unterstützung eine Option ist
ich denke für Europa ist sie keine
Option wie sie sagen europa muss die
Ukraine unterstützen weil Russlands
Bedrohungen ist aber viel vor allem die
republikanische Partei ist die
Unterstützung der Ukraine mittlerweile
einen hochkontoversystem zum Thema und
Trump der wahrscheinlichste Kandidat hat
sich da sehr distanziert gezeigt es ist
gar nicht diskutiert hier dass die
beiden mit ministröhrchen die
Möglichkeit hat da die Stimmen zusammen
zu bekommen um man sagt wir brauchen
einen Erfolg als die Amerikaner mögen
eine Erfolgsgeschichte die Ukraine wenn
sie es ihnen gelingt einen
entsprechenden Durchbruch einen Gewinn
gewisse Weise zu erzielen aufgrund der
Investitionen und man muss ja auch klar
sagen dass die militärische Investition
der Amerikaner massiv sind in der
Ukraine das kommt ja nicht aus Europa
das Material sondern vor allem aus
Amerika sie wollen einen Ertrag sehen
für diese Investitionen und wenn das
nicht da ist denken wir glaube ich dass
September Uhren Generalversammlung der
wahrscheinlichste Moment ist für einen
ziemlich massiven Druck von
amerikanische Seite dann kommt das
Kongress wieder zusammen wir gehen dann
richtig in die in die Wahl in die
Wahlkampagnen da das ist glaube ich ganz
entscheidend für Kief bis dahin
Momentum wirklich zu reisen für wen oder
besser gesagt für wie wichtig wäre ein
Sieg ein Erfolg in dieser Offensive für
evoluto music
halt in seinem eigenen Land ich meine
das geht dann auch auf die Friedensfrage
zurück denn die die Frieden Verhandlung
beginnen erst nach Erschöpfung weil die
Politik der Aushandlungen eines Friedens
für allem für eine Demokratie wir haben
Deutschland hat ja damit wirklich
tiefste Erfahrung gemacht fast unmöglich
ist jeder kommt jeder Frieden berühmte
auf Kompromisse und nach den Opfern die
die Ukraine gebracht hat ist im
Gegenteil es ist unmöglich Kompromisse
zu akzeptieren und für sehr Lenski ist
die Situation glaube ich wirklich
hochkommt also gerade zu trage weil die
einzige der einzige wirklich gute
Ausgang für ihn ist ein entscheidender
Sieg auf dem schachtelfeld und das ist
einfach nicht abzusehen dass er das
gelingt um auch nach einem kriegsen
sagen es gibt natürlich immer wir alle
wissen und das da geben ja seit 16
Monaten durch es gibt den Nebel des
Krieges es ist natürlich nicht
auszuschließen dass es den Ukrainern
gelingt ob jetzt alleine oder mit Hilfe
der amerikanischen Aufklärung eine
fundamentale Schwachstelle in der
russischen Verteidigungslinie zu
entdecken und dann doch sozusagen
einige schnelle Erfolge möglich sein
werden also ich gehe davon aus dass es
eigentlich langfristig werden wird und
man kann nie ausschließen dass es
irgendwo wirklich diese Schwachstelle
gibt die entdeckt wird und das war ja
auch im Juni Juli 22 der Fall und dann
zumindestens partiell irgendwo massive
Durchbrüche sind das würde schon reichen
um es in den USA aber auch in Europa als
Erfolg zu verkaufen
ich war im Dezember in den Vereinigten
Staaten um den mit dem gerade in
operierten Vorsitzenden
Verteidigungsausschusses dort zu
sprechen
sehr konservativ und aber ich kann das
nur bestätigen und er sagte zu mir ich
kann gar nicht verstehen dass der Krieg
noch gar nicht gewonnen ist also nach
dem Motto jetzt ist das schon seit
Monaten dran jetzt macht mal hinne und
deswegen sagte er auch und da war er
ganz eng bei den Demokraten wir müssen
mehr tun wir müssen mehr liefern ich
glaube deswegen in der Tat braucht es
zwischen Erfolge und wenn ich das so
sagen darf die Stimmung dort zu erhalten
das dramatische am Krieg ist ja dass der
Wunsch immer ist kurz und heftig weil
natürlich die Akzeptanz in den eigenen
Reihen bei denen die helfen in der
Bevölkerung natürlich je länger der
Krieg nachlässt auch die Aufmerksamkeit
nachlässt ähm ich würde allerdings die
den den Willen die Kampfkraft auch die
Unterstützung es sind natürlich viele
finden die Amerikaner aber es sind 50
Staaten die die Ukraine mit Material
unterstützen unterschiedlichste Art da
gehört im Winter übrigens auch
entsprechende Kleidung dazu das nämlich
Soldaten nicht erfrieren im Feld das die
Unterstützung so groß ist dass ich den
Ukraine durchaus zutraue auch angesichts
der Aufklärung das wird ja aufgeklärt
sie haben vorhin ein Bild gezeigt wo ein
Soldat im Schützengraben ist ja der ist
im Schützengraben das sind die Bilder
des Ersten Weltkriegs aber mit einer
völlig anderen Technologie mit Hightech
mit drohnenaufklärung und dass dadurch
aus Gegenstöße zu erwarten sind das
glaube ich schon jetzt können
wenn ich mir das andere ich gebe Ihnen
recht was sie gerade gesagt haben ich
glaube schon das ist so ist dass die USA
da einen Erfolg brauchen aber ich meine
in der Zeit sterben in der Ukraine jeden
Tag die Menschen es geht nicht dass sie
wir brauchen Erfolg brauchen
keine Erinnerungen
ab ich meine das eine solche Kontingenz
mit der konfrontiert sind in diesem
Moment genau wie sie sagen irgendwie
brauchen wir einen Schlüssel zur
russischen Position vielleicht gelegt
ist vielleicht gibt es nicht und und die
Weltlage hängt von dieser vom von der
eigennissen auf dem Schlachtfeld ab ich
meine das ist einmalig in Erneuerung
Geschichte
ich meine es ist ja auch so das muss man
ja auch dazu sagen es läuft ja viel
Diplomatie im Hintergrund das ist ja es
wird immer so gesagt dass wir brauchen
diplomatische es läuft ja viel
Diplomatie also ich meine ich glaube der
chinesische
Sondergesandte für die Ukraine war jetzt
vor zwei oder drei Tagen in Deutschland
oder sowas es läuft seitens Amerikaner
viel Diplomatie im Hintergrund die
Amerikaner treffen sich mit den Chinesen
für zwei Tage da läuft ja viel das
Problem ist halt nur ja im Vordergrund
läuft
deshalb nicht so gut weil es einen
Akteur gibt der keinerlei Interesse
zeigt sozusagen sich an den
verhandlungssicht zu begeben und das ist
Vladimir Putin also wir haben zum
Beispiel gesehen ja das war jetzt keine
so gute diplomatische Initiative
nichts zu tun
ja aber ich glaube schon dass es gut
wäre wenn unsere Außenministerin nach
China reist und versucht der gute
Beziehungen aufzubauen weil Kinder ja
ein wichtiger Akteur sein kann um
zufriedensverhandlungen kommen
vielleicht kommen wir noch mal zurück zu
interessantes
interessante Nachricht dass Bruno Karl
der BND-Chef sagt dass er in dem System
von Wladimir Putin keine Risse sieht und
der österreichische Außenminister
resigniert mit weiteren zehn Jahren
Wladimir Putin rechnet das ist auch noch
mal eine Frage Frau Zimmermann sie ja
also rechnen wir jetzt alle damit dass
wir am Ende mit dem Menschen
verhandeln müssen der diese Gold hatten
in der Ukraine angetan
hat das wissen wir ja alles gar nicht
als Russland die Ukraine Angriff wurde
kolportiert Putin sei so aufgedunsten
der sei wahrscheinlich krank und würde
morgen tot umfallen
Spekulation was wir wissen von
Offizieren russischen Offizieren die
desertiert sind dahingehend dass er sich
völlig verschanzt hat dass er seine sein
Leben lebt und auch nur die
Informationen noch akzeptiert die in
seinem Weltbild passen das ist natürlich
nicht gut denn das was wir alle wollen
diplomatische Beziehung Gespräche das
basiert ja auf einem gewissen
kultivierter des Lebens nach dem Motto
es ist gestritten wir müssen ein Ende
finden wenn der das Gegenüber das aber
komplett ausschließt und es geht ja noch
weiter Wladimir Putin spricht ja nicht
nur in Anführungszeichen über die
Ostukraine also über den Frontverlauf
jetzt sondern er träumt davon die
komplette Ukraine einzunehmen damit
inklusive der Krim ja und auch damit
auch Belarus mit reinzuziehen nämlich
entsprechende Waffen in Belarus zu
stationieren um sozusagen auch von der
Seite anzugreifen und das ist natürlich
ein Szenario das überhaupt nicht da
hinweist dass in mit einer Form
russischerseits
friedenswünsche da sind aber ich glaube
diese die diese Bewegung auch im
russischen Militär dass die wagnergruppe
sich jetzt zurückzieht machen die ja
nicht weil das in wachmut alles so toll
gelaufen ist sondern weil die
wagnergruppen unvorstellbar viele
Soldaten verloren haben also eher gar
keine andere Wahl hat die Diskussion
also auch auch innerhalb des Militärs
russisches militärverser
Wagner zeigt eben auch dass auch im
Militär dadurch aus Risse entstehen und
was das für eine Dynamik werden kann
aber es ist können wir nur vermuten ich
habe mir jetzt trotzdem auch noch mal
die Krim vor die persönliche Linse
gepackt aber er gab aber es ist ja im
Grunde ein völlig nächstes rationales
Problem sich vorzustellen dass Putin die
Krim behalten möchte und das wurde mir
silenski die Krimi wieder zurück haben
möchte Putin betrachtet sie als
russisches Gebiet und wolle gesagt dass
ist ukrainisches
deshalb weil wir als nächstes Jahr auch
gleich noch mal über diese F16 reden
werden und die Ukraine also zurecht
natürlich das Ziel hat diese Halbinsel
zurückzubekommen so wenn sich da ich mag
mir das gar nicht vorstellen ist das
denn die nächste Eskalation dieses
ohnehin schon grausamen Kriege ist
also das habe ich ja gemeint damit dass
beide Seiten strategische Ziele
verfolgen die sich natürlich
ausschließen sonst gibt es den Krieg ja
nicht und war zu sagen was ich glaube wo
ein bisschen Hoffnung existieren kann
das ist in der Tat das nach dieser
Offensive die lang und blutig sein wird
möglicherweise doch auf beiden Seiten
die Einschätzung da ist das jedenfalls
eine Pause eingelegt werden muss das
heißt nicht dass es ein Friedensvertrag
gibt das heißt auch nicht das ist
irgendwie ein zettelement gibt sondern
das erstmal für eine gewisse Zeit die
Waffen schweigen oder nicht genauso
stark sprechen können und dass man in
dieser Situation international dann
tatsächlich zu ernsthafteren Gesprächen
kommen kann das eine wahre Hoffnung die
ich auch deshalb habe weil ich natürlich
sehe dass der Rest der Welt ganz anders
auf diesen Konflikt schaut dieser dieser
dieser dieser Krieg hat den Westen
geeint und die Welt gespalten und es
gibt ein massiv dem Druck aus vielen
anderen Ländern die aufgrund der
Energiepreise der Lebensmittel einfach
nicht ertragen können dass das nicht zum
Ende kommt und ich fand den Hinweis dass
Amerika mit China redet enorm wichtig
denn das war am Anfang ja nicht so
inzwischen glaube ich gibt es in Amerika
die klare Einschätzung am Ende werden
die Chinesen mit am Verhandlungstisch
sitzen schon deshalb weil Russland in
jedem Fall überhaupt nur verhandeln wird
wenn da auch jemand sitzt der russische
Interessen vertritt und deswegen ist es
eine ziemlich kluge Vorgehensweise der
Amerikaner und das Weißen Hauses zu
versuchen jedenfalls Kontakte dorthin
wieder zu mobilisieren und die Chinesen
einzubinden die Chinesen selber haben
was Europa angeht ja auch ihre Strategie
geändert sie haben gedacht sie können
uns Spalten
16+1 solche Gruppen und zusammen gesehen
das geht nicht und auf einmal werden sie
diplomatisch aktiv und wollen versuchen
hier eine Rolle zu spielen also da gibt
es Bewegung und die hat viel damit zu
tun dass natürlich weder die USA noch
die Chinesen zulassen wollen dass sie im
Rest der Welt als diejenigen angesehen
werden die nichts dazu beitragen diesen
Konflikt zu verändern das ändert alles
nichts an Russlands Position die ist
vorhin richtig beschrieben worden aber
wenn die Chinesen den Russen
signalisieren ihr müsst jetzt mitmachen
dann ist das eine andere Ausgangslage
aber am Ende ich glaube du hast das
irgendwo geschrieben oder gesagt wird
das wenn das immer
unangenehm um es vorsichtig auszudrücken
Abschlüsse werden das wird keinen sauber
entscheidend ist wo sozusagen der eine
alles zurück kriegt oder der andere
alles behält sondern das werden wie in
all diesen Konflikten sehr unangenehme
Entscheidungen sein die vielleicht dann
auch nicht auf ewig halten und da kommt
dann F16 und andere ins Spiel die
Ukraine so auszustatten dass sie nicht
in Gefahr ist dass die Russen nach einer
längeren Pause oder oder irgendeiner
Pause wieder loslegen sondern dass die
Ukraine kontinuierlich in die Lage
versetzt wird sich zu verteidigen denn
am Ende wird es eher so Lösungen geben
wie für Israel und Japan und nicht eine
NATO-Mitgliedschaft die Amerikaner haben
jedenfalls relativ klar in den letzten
Wochen zu verstehen gegeben dass sie
niemals in die Lage kommen wollen mit
einer nuklear macht wie Russland
unmittelbar in den Krieg zu kommen und
deswegen wird es nicht so schnell zu
einer NATO Mitgliedschaft kommen sondern
andere Form und deshalb ist die
Unterstützung und Kampfflugzeugen so
wichtig wir versuchen es noch mal so
einen kleinen Schritt zurück und checken
vielleicht noch mal einen bei dem
Gedanken zuvor also jetzt ja also noch
nicht die NATO sondern China welche
Rolle spielt die Auseinandersetzung und
Unterstützung die seitens der Chinesen
für Russland und seitens der
US-Amerikaner für die Europäer kommen
sehen Sie das ähnlich wie Herr Gabriel
das China da eine große Rolle spielt
erstens mal hat Wladimir christina hat
er angegriffen war vorher in China wir
erinnern uns ja die Olympischen Spiele
abgewartet und dann startete der Angriff
er hat sich da natürlich grünes Licht
geholt und ich glaube nicht nur Russland
sondern auch die Chinesen reiben sich
die Augen wie Europa steht dass die NATO
steht und sogar noch wächst um Länder
die jahrzehntelang bündnisneutral waren
für China ist dieser Krieg lästig weil
natürlich auch China ganz knallharte
wirtschaftliche Interessen hat erstens
möchte ich China mit Europa im Handel
bleiben zweitens bekommt ja China die
Dynamik jetzt dass wir in Europa
anfangen nach der Abhängigkeit
russischen Energie auch darüber zu
diskutieren und zwar laut und deutlich
wie abhängig sind wir eigentlich von
China das kann China überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen und insofern sind diese
Gespräche zwischen den Vereinigten
Staaten und China so wichtig weil das
wiederum auch ausschließen wird dass sie
im indukt eine militärische
Auseinandersetzung gibt weil das kann
ich Ihnen noch weniger gebrauchen und
wenn man zusammen am Tisch sitzt ist
natürlich die Gefahr dass etwas
eskaliert definitiv abgemeldet also
insofern die Chinesen spielen da eine
große Rolle und sie spielen eine neue
Rolle und sie spielen eine andere Rolle
als zuvor weil auch sie etwas
dazugelernt haben jetzt ist trotzdem die
Frage zugelernt und weil es ihr also die
Chinesen haben nur einen eigenen und das
ist ihr eigene Macht nach Hause wenn ja
stimmt die größte Wirtschafts- und
militärische Macht zu werden und da ist
dieser Krieg lästig von dem sie
angenommen haben dass der ganz schnell
erledigt ist das Russland dann eben im
Land annektiert und dann leben wir
fröhlich weiter weil wir ja bis dato
auch nie gezeigt haben dass Europa
resilientes europaabwehrbereit ist und
insofern wird China da schon eine Rolle
spielen gut die sind noch mal beim
Ordnen und fragen Sie noch nicht gleich
nach China sondern noch mal nach dem
Engagement und der Europäer sie haben
vorhin gesagt dass der Amerikaner in
militärischer Hinsicht war riesig dass
der Europäer eigentlich nicht so könnten
wir mehr also hätten wir mehr tun können
um die Ukraine militärisch zu
unterstützen ja ich denke die beleicht
aber ich denke der der wirkliche Beitrag
der geh hinkte zunächst war der
wirtschaftliche ich meine entscheidend
für das Überlebende Ukraine ist ja auf
einmal auf der einen Seite die
Ereignisse auf dem Schlachtfeld und das
das andere dass man nicht genug
betrachtet ist die Heimatfront und der
Zusammenhalt der ukrainischen
Gesellschaft sie hat diese riesige
Tapferkeit gezeigt aber das beruht
letztendlich auf einer Heimat von die
auch halten muss und von die ukrainische
Wirtschaft also von Russland gar nicht
zu reden die ukrainische Wirtschaft
erleidet ja ein ein massiven Schaden ja
über ein bruttosozialprodukteinbruch von
30% also
absolut massiv und das das zögerliche in
der wirtschaftlichen finanziellen
Unterstützung im letzten Jahr war
wirklich ein armutstag muss man so sagen
es ist gut dass das jetzt schneller
läuft dass das jetzt planmäßiger läuft
dass die Größenordnung richtig sind aber
angesichts der der der
Bestände einfach an militärischen mit
Material das in zur Verfügung steht
denke ich dass das die primäre Rolle
sein muss so jetzt machen wir noch mal
den Sprung dass
selensky gelungen ist diese
Kampfjet Allianz zusammen zu bekommen
und auch die Unterstützung von Joe Biden
dafür zu bekommen die Amerikaner haben
lange gezögert darüber haben wir hier
auch schon viel geredet worin sich
dieses Zögern auch begründete nämlich um
eigentlich zu vermeiden dass die Ukraine
russisches Territorium erreichen können
nochmal die krimfrage ben horchester ist
hier das letzte Mal und sagte die Creme
ist der entscheidende Punkt in dieser
Schlacht wenn es den Ukrainern gelingt
die Krim zu kriegen dann haben sie den
Krieg gewonnen wenn es Ihnen nicht
gelingt wird es immer ein frozen
Konflikt bleiben ein eingefrorener Krieg
bleiben nicken sie und sagen sie ja weil
dann haben wir dieses definitorische
Problem Putin sagt die Creme ist unser
und die Ukraine sagen wir müssen sie
zurück und ich meine Gabriel deshalb
geht der Krieg weiter denn unter diesen
Bedingungen unter diesen Umständen zu
diskutieren es ist für beide Seiten
politisch unmöglich ich denke die F16
ist mittlerweile in die Zukunft gerückt
auch da hat Herr Gabriel absolut recht
F16 ist gewisser Weise entfernt ein
sicherheits-signal in Sachen Israel den
anderen Worten keine wird nicht
untergehen darf nicht verlieren und wir
geben Ihnen auch sehr hochwertige Waffen
dafür würde ja die Ukraine aber auch
erreichen dass sie die Brücke von Gerd
schützen kann also nicht die
amerikanische Intention so das was man
bisher herausfinden kann
um diesen neuen zuhören also das ist
sehr präzise formulieren sagen sie F 16
ist für die Zukunft da geht es um die
die Ordnung danach da geht es um
abschreckungsfähigkeit im Grunde nicht
um die Lösung der krimfrage und das ist
bitte genug weil die Ukraine bräuchten
ist dir dieses militärische Material um
eine Chance zu haben diese Halbinsel
eigentlich dann abzuschneiden von der
Versorgung nein also die Ukraine haben
Sturm Shadow geliefert bekommen und die
stormscheidung kann die von dem dritten
die könnte Theorie ich weiß dass die
Briten Auflagen gemacht haben ich weiß
nicht welche aber ich weiß dass sie
Aufladen gemacht haben aber potenziell
könnte die Storm Shadow die Brücke in
Schutt und Asche legen Punkt dazu
brauchen Sie keine S6 die sind aber noch
nicht da aber die kommen früher als die
kommen früher können sich die Ukraine
dann wenigstens verlassen wir sind jetzt
bei der Frage nach den Verhandlungen und
der rollias ähm der Bogen ist
tatsächlich groß in der Sendung aber es
ist so wichtig dass zu verstehen
ähm auf der anderen Seite der auch wie
gut welche Positionen sehen sie haben
die Chinesen tatsächlich auch da als ein
friedensvermittler und welche
Möglichkeiten haben sie dazu um eben
Putin auch zu beeinflussen ich habe
riesige Möglichkeiten es ist bestimmt
der entscheidende macht externe
machtfraktur wirklich bezeichnet im
wirtschaftlichen Gebet ist inwieweit die
Chinesen Druck auf die Russen
auszuübenden Sachen Gaslieferung also
diese sibirische Pipeline die die die
Russen eifern sich dafür versprechen
immer wieder dass das Deal im Grunde
unter abgemacht ist aber die Chinesen
zögern immer wieder beim letzten Besuch
beidseitigen Besuch kam doch kein Geld
dabei heraus also dieses Paar
ist ein ein enorme
verhandlungspotenz und Potenzial das
Budget jetzt sehr gezielt gegen Moskau
außer spät es war schon 14 der Fall nach
der ersten Runde von Aktion
der Preis geht für die für die für die
Russen nie durch mit dem Gas und für die
Chinesen steigt der Mehrwert also da ich
meine in Russland redet man ja gewisser
Weise um die die Verknechtung also die
versklave Russland seitens der Chinesen
das also hier jetzt eine historische
Unterordnung stattfindet und sich
verkehrt
genau und genau wie sie sagen dass die
chinesische Position jetzt eine ganz
neuartige ist wenn das ins Spiel
gebracht wird dann verändert sich die
Lage für Moskau bisher ist es sehr
diskret sie scheitern aber die Chinesen
machen es nicht offensichtlich dass sie
scheitern die Dosen sich produziert sie
probieren es noch mal wenn es
tatsächlich zu einem Bruch käme das wäre
dann auch zu einem öffentlichen Bruch
das wäre für Moskau wirklich eine sehr
schwierige Lage
ist keine Frage sie kaufen ja auch das
die Energie auf die wir nicht mehr
kaufen und der Preis fällt aber ich
meine da funktioniert nicht Sanktion
also die Öl Sanktionen
aber
entscheidend
hinzufügen darf das natürlich China
eine Sache hat dieses in der Tat mit
Russland verbindet und das ist die
Ablehnung der Demokratie und der
Freiheit in der wir leben das ist das
Bindeglied nicht Wirtschaft und sonst
und da werden sie glaube ich den
öffentlichen Streit reduzieren um nicht
Schwäche zu zeigen im Grunde genommen
den Amerikanern und den Westen
unabhängig davon ob sie das öffentlich
machen oder nicht was man den Punkt den
man nicht vergessen hat einen Zusatz hat
gerade eben angedeutet wir haben ja eine
interessante Erfahrung im letzten halben
Jahr gemacht die Chinesen sind plötzlich
auch politischer Vermittler zwischen
Saudi Arabien und Iran so die Chinesen
war nie politische Vermittler also sie
haben sich einmal im Sudan vor ich weiß
ich fast 10 Jahren als politischer
Vermittler betätigt aber das lag daran
dass irgendwie glaube ich zwei Minen
kurzer Vorstand von Rebellen eingenommen
zu werden jetzt sind sie in der Ukraine
tätig für die Chinesen ist das natürlich
die Funktion das zu erreichen was sie
eigentlich wollen auf der Augenhöhe mit
den Amerikanern sozusagen über die
Ordnung
der internationalen Politik zu reden das
darf man nicht vergessen also da geht es
nicht nur um ökonomische Gründe da geht
es nicht nur darum dass die Chinesen
sozusagen das nicht gut finden dass der
Krieg so lange dauert dann bin ich mir
nämlich zum Beispiel gar nicht so sicher
weil er bindet ja sehr viel
amerikanische Ressourcen hier die
woanders fehlen nämlich in Asien
aber es geht den Chinesen hier das zu
benutzen als Hebel um das zu erreichen
was sie eigentlich wollen nämlich nicht
die Multipolarität von denen sie immer
mit den anderen reden sondern die
Bipolarität seine Vereinigten Staaten
und die Augenhöhe wir sind Frau Mohammed
Ali noch mal bei der Frage des Nutzens
der Sanktionen das klang jetzt hier
schon an interessanterweise fordern sie
von ihre Partei die Sanktionen die
bestehen aufzulösen das macht sonst
eigentlich nur die AFD warum nicht
korrekt also was wir gesagt haben müssen
Sanktion natürlich gegen unmittelbar
gegen das Militär die natürlich erhalten
bleiben müssen auch Sanktion gegen die
Oligarchen sollten erhalten bleiben und
sollten auch endlich mal ich sag mal auf
eine Art und Weise ausgestaltet sein
dass Sie auch wirklich wirken aber die
Energie Sanktionen da sieht man dass die
in der Bilanz Deutschland Europa mehr
geschadet haben als Russland also es
gibt keine Erkenntnisse darüber das sagt
auch die AFD
es gibt keine Erkenntnisse darüber dass
die Energie Sanktionen Russlands
Kriegsmaschinerie in irgendeiner Form
gebremst haben Deutschland befindet sich
inzwischen offiziellen eine Rezession
Russland nicht das muss man ja mal sehen
die letzte Runde der Sanktion also diese
Maßnahmen um den preisdag zu bereiten
Preis zu deckeln zeigen sehr starke
Wirkung mittlerweile ist es kommt kam ja
zu einem wirklich haben ein Einbruch in
den öl-einnahmen und dreiviertel davon
geht auf geht auf die Sanktion zurück
das ist ja eine sehr klugemaßnahme des
Öl läuft weiter in den Markt die Inder
und die Chinesen können sich eindecken
und verkaufen ist
wichtig stabilisiert die einzigen
wirklichen Verlierer sind die Russen bei
der Preis niedrig ist und wir geben den
Kindern ja Verhandlungsmacht weil die
weil die Russen genau wissen dass sie
das nicht überhaupt verkaufen können
der Preis den wir den ein Land wie
Deutschland zahlt natürlich auch groß
ist und es ist innerhalb Europas ja auch
hat er kämpft gewesen und die glaube
dass du beim Südens haben auch einen
hohen Preis bezahlt für die
energieaktion die auf dem Energie nicht
mehr kaufen konnten weil es zu teuer
geworden war ja das ist einfach mal eine
Realität die die da stattgefunden hat
und das muss man doch sehen ist auch
eine gewisse
auch da nicht mitmachen wollten das in
der Konsequenzen die man da bedenken
muss und es ist so die russische
Wirtschaft die steht nicht vor kurzem
Kollaps es wurde damals gesagt wir
werden Russland ruinieren diesen
Sanktion das ist nicht eingetragen
[Musik]
die Erwartungen größer waren als das was
eingetreten ist auf der anderen Seite
muss man ganz einfach sehen wir wissen
historisch gesehen immer Sanktionen
wirken nicht so stark innerhalb von 12
13 Monaten das dauert nicht so schnell
ja das dauert entwickeln und noch mal ja
wir zahlen den Preis dafür sozusagen
aber letzten Endes ist der größere Preis
den wir zahlen würden ist die Sicherheit
und Stabilität Europas das muss man
einfach mal ganz klar so sehen
Außenministerin das ist ja nur so
gewesen natürlich werden Sie sie auf
lange Sicht in die Knie zwingen nur
Sanktionen sind immer langfristig
angelegt schauen sich das Verhältnis an
der Stadt der am meisten sanktioniert
war Russland ist in einem Maße
sanktioniert
sein die deutsche Wirtschaft wird nicht
sagen
Russland wird in einem Maße sagen zu mir
wie es historisch nicht vorher da war
ein anderer Vergleich weniger
sanktioniert ist der Iran da hat man
Sanktionen die Wirkung von Sanktionen
nach vier fünf sechs Jahren gesehen so
das dauert noch mal ich antworte auf ihr
Argument sie können jetzt gerne Ausweis
nicht antworten
nein ihr Argument war sozusagen das hat
die Wirtschaft nicht in die Knie
gezwungen und wir wissen dass Sanktionen
das ist gut ist auch nicht korrekt denn
wir sehen auch dass in Russland eine
wahre Kriegswirtschaft herrscht das
nämlich Industrie Dinge nicht mehr
hergestellt werden weil alles sich
darauf konzentriert Waffen herzustellen
weil eben die die Lieferkette auch
diesbezüglich nicht mehr so läuft easy
läuft und noch mal zurückgehend hätten
sie ernsthaft nach dem Russland diese
Ukraine knechtet und ich muss das immer
wieder sagen das sterben tausende da
werden Frauen vergewaltigt 20.000 Kinder
sind den Kindern den Eltern weggenommen
worden angesichts dessen wir Energie
dort einkaufen als ob uns das alles
nichts interessiert das ist der Preis
den wir wir kompensieren ja eine Menge
das ist der Preis den wir bezahlen für
unsere Freiheit und für ein Signal nach
Russland dass wir diese Form des
Imperialismus oder kein Umständen
akzeptieren aber da möchte ich doch
schon darauf reagieren können also wenn
es denn so wäre das durch die Energie
Sanktionen dieser Krieg jetzt gestoppt
worden wäre wenn es wirklich so gewesen
wäre dass die Ukraine dadurch ist
befreite werden können hätte ich dir
auch eine andere Meinung das ist aber
nicht der Fall das ist erkennbar nicht
der Fall das heißt die Stellen ist so da
als wären diese Sanktionen die sind
Effekt nicht hatten die andere Länder im
großen Schwierigkeiten gebracht haben
die zum Teil zum Teil zu
versorgungsausfällen in Ländern ist
globalen Südens geführt haben dass das
sozusagen das einzige Mittel gewesen ist
das zu machen
können und sie stellen es so da das
einfach mal der Preis den man bezahlt
wie ein haben hier in Deutschland erlebt
dass Menschen in echte Not geraten sind
weil sie ihre Energierechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen konnten das hat sie vielleicht
nicht aber viele Menschen krass das
Ergebnis
sie lenken ja gerade von dem Thema ab
nämlich sie sprechen vom globalen Süden
da können wir gerne darüber sprechen von
den hemmissen dass die Ukraine nicht
sehen kann damit auch nicht mehr ernten
kann sind 190 Millionen Menschen
betroffen inzwischen sind große Flächen
der Ukraine Familien das heißt auch wenn
der Krieg zu Ende ist dies diese
tausenden aus den Feldern rausgenommen
wurde aus dieser Kornkammer Europas
wird uns Jahre ich möchte nicht dass die
Geschichte von ihnen anders beschrieben
wird nein das
schlichtweg Millionen von der Energie
werden angesichts und Sie haben Recht
sie haben sie haben Recht sie haben
Recht mit der Analyse dass das in der
Tat dieser Krieg auch dazu führt dass
die Länder das globalen Südens
1990 Millionen doch recht aber das ist
doch ein Grund warum man darauf
hinwirken muss dass dieser Krieg
möglichst schnell Ende du Fuß schüttelt
weil die Anspannung im globalen
gasmakler von Russland ausgegangen also
wir haben ja keine Sanktionen gegen
russisches Gas verhängt es ist wahre
Entscheidung uns abzuschneiden und nicht
umgekehrt die die die die einzig
wirksame energiemaßnahmen die wir
erhoben haben
und die greifen jetzt die greifen jetzt
erst eigentlich in den letzten paar
Monaten und sie Schein recht wirksam zu
sein und sie sind gerade so ausgelegt
dass der globale Süden dadurch ein
Gewitter ist weil wir den weil wir den
Preis nach unten hebe
und weil wir den über die die die die
die der Kollateralschaden für den
globalen Süden im letzten Jahr entstand
ja in der Hauptsache durch die
Ausweichbewegung der Europäer unter
anderem auch Deutschland ja richtig den
banglade des Uni Pakistan ist weggekauft
haben aber der Auslöser davon weil die
russische Entscheidung natürlich durch
uns provoziert ich meine wir haben uns
entgegengestellt und sie haben wir haben
Wirtschaft erkriegt durch die Krieg
geführt durch die Sanktion gegen ihre
Zentralbank und dann haben sie
zurückgeschlagen also das ist ein eine
Wechselwirkung hier in der im Grunde
Europa sehr zu zögerlich war in der in
dem Ergreifen von Energie Sanktion und
jetzt erst sehen wir ob sie
funktionieren die Funktion wird sein die
Kaufkraft Russlands zu vermindern denn
die Sanktionen die Import Sanktionen die
für die Kriegsführung entscheiden sind
greifen ja nur wenn den Russen das Geld
ausgeht solange die Russen wirklich
starke einkommensströmen haben werden
sie alle Hindernisse über
überwältigen können
die großen mit ihrer geballten Kaufkraft
durch Öl und gaseinnahmen kommen dann
greifen die Sanktion nicht sie werden
Drittländer finden mit denen sie das
machen können wir müssen die Russen arm
machen also Ihnen diese Einnahmen
wegnehmen und da sind diese Öl
Sanktionen wirklich der der Königsweg
und wir sind er im Grunde haben wir
einen Quartal gemacht wir müssen also
wirklich sehen wie das jetzt über das
gesamte Jahr läuft die Weltkonjunktur
kann vielleicht unsere Hände spielen und
dann werden wir sehen wie es im Kanal
aussieht wenn sie wirklich unter
finanzpolitischen Druck kommen das ist
ein neues Szenario Herr Gabriel
schließen Sie sich an
Sinn Unsinn dieser Sanktionen
Debatte so als hätten der Westen oder
Europa
gastanktionen gegen Russland verhängt
das war Russland dass die
Energielieferungen gestoppt hat und
nicht etwa Europa es gab gar keine
Entscheidung darüber ich stelle mir
gerade mal vor wir würden in dieser
Situation weiter russisches Gast kaufen
wir hätten jede Kredibilität verloren
die würde eigentlich die Welt auf uns
gucken wie würden die Ukraine auf uns
gucken was machen würden
so sehr ich das Argument Teile das
dieser Krieg die Welt gespalten hat das
wäre eine Last die wir gar nicht tragen
könnten ich finde auch interessant wie
kriegt man sozusagen Russland über diese
Ölsanktionen und auch über andere
Maßnahmen weiter wirtschaftlich unter
Druck und wie stark kann man die
Chinesen davon überzeugen dass eine
Fortsetzung dieses Krieges
unverhältnismäßig große Risiken für die
Weltwirtschaft
beinhaltet denn das ist das was China
scheut wieder Teufel das Weihwasser
dieses Land ist jetzt schon in
Schwierigkeiten wirtschaftlich die Macht
der KP hängt davon ab dass einigermaßen
Wohlstand im Land existiert was die
überhaupt nicht wollen in erstens in die
Nähe von Sanktionen deswegen liefern sie
den Russen eben keine Waffen und das
zweite ist sie haben auch Sorge von der
größeren weltwirtschaftlichen Rezession
das ist der Hebel um China dazu zu
bewegen stärker Druck auf Russland
auszuüben was wir alle nicht wissen ist
wie sich Wladimir Putin und seine
kameria entscheiden wird das übrigens
war vorhin ein bisschen vielleicht auch
noch die Lücke bei der Krim Debatte die
Zurückhaltung bei der Lieferung
bestimmter Waffensysteme diese rote
Linie nicht direkt mit Russland einen
Konflikt gehen zu wollen hat ja alles
den Hintergrund dass man nicht so
richtig kalkulieren kann zu was er
bereit wäre wenn er wirklich vor einer
echten Niederlage Wände und das ist eine
unkalkulierbare Größe und da glaube ich
ist jedenfalls
Vorsicht reden mit den Chinesen
die richtige harngehensweise und nicht
schneidigkeit ich glaube da hilft uns
das Vorgehen dass wir bisher gesehen
haben auch übrigens bei der deutschen
Bundesregierung und im Kanzler immer
wieder mit den Chinesen zu reden viel
weiter als alle möglichen Spekulationen
was die Ukraine jetzt schafft oder nicht
mit dem chinesischen Präsidenten
hingestellt und hat auch Richtung
Russland auch das ausgesprochen nämlich
Russland soll sich nicht mal an Gedanken
darüber machen eine atomare Waffe
einzusetzen das war ja ein sehr großes
Zeichen an der Stelle hat der Kanzler
übrigens das auch mit initiiert das war
wirklich eine ein ganz wichtiger Schritt
das in diesem Moment diese beiden
Systemgegner sich ganz klar artikuliert
haben ich glaube das war von ganz ganz
großer Bedeutung
Olaf Scholz mittlerweile
Zimmermann das Problem das Problem ist
meine Sorge es gibt nicht nur die
Möglichkeit das Russland zu Atomwaffen
greift das Land kann sich zu einem jeder
Krieg ist schon eine Ausweis ein
chirurgenstaat aber wir benutzen den
Begriff schurkenstart ja auch für Länder
die dann versuchen asymmetrische
Kriegsführung zu machen uns im
Heimatland anzugreifen mit Cyber mit
Terror-Attacken und anderen auch das
muss man leider Russland zutrauen also
es ist nicht so dass es nur aus meiner
Sicht nur um das Thema Nuklearwaffen
geht sondern es gibt leider noch viele
andere Dinge die bleiben immer Putin in
die Wege leiten können und auch dafür
ist am Ende China der richtige
Ansprechpartner um zu versuchen solche
Bedürfnisse die Russland entwickeln kann
wenn es echt in die Enge gedrängt wird
nicht wirklich zur Wahrheit geworden
sind Stabilisierung der deutschen
Gesellschaft läuft ja schon seit Monaten
von tausenden von Trollen die im Netz
versuchen unsere Gesellschaft zu spalten
und es gelingt leider auch verstärkt
dass Leute eben wirklich jeden
Schwachsinn glauben der ihnen da
serviert wird ohne zu hinterfragen ob
das überhaupt sein kann was da
geschrieben
stehtattacken also nicht in ganz Europa
so ich wollte gerne noch mal zur
deutschen Politik kommen und eigentlich
Frau stark Zimmermann fragen
ob und wie sehr der Kanzler mittlerweile
auf sie hört Frau station was sie sagen
ich nehme an er hört auf seine Frau und
ich finde das sollte auch reichen nein
aber ich glaube dass der Bundeskanzler
der ja auch eingebettet ist in seine
Partei in seinem Umfeld in diesen 15
Monaten natürlich auch registriert hat
dass diese Zurückhaltung letztendlich
nicht hilft dass das auch nicht
wahrgenommen wird das wenn Russland
erkennt ja nur die Ernsthaftigkeit und
die Sprache und die Tat und nicht ein
eine ein soft-weg und ich glaube einfach
dass der Kanzler natürlich auch mit
vielen sei es dass er mit selenski sehr
oft zusammengetroffen ist da ist dass er
sich verabredet mit äh auch erst in der
späteren Phase sehr zusammen ja aber
auch dieses zusammenkommen mit anderen
mit dem britischen Premium nicht alle
auf Französisch
wenn er dann alleine übrig bleibt
während die anderen sich damit
beschäftigen was kann man tun ich glaube
die Rolle will der Bundeskanzler nun
auch nicht
ja ich glaube es sind zwei Motive ich
glaube das eine ist und das gilt
sozusagen nicht nur für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland das gilt auch
für die USA man hat über die 15 Monate
die dieser Krieg jetzt dauert oder gar
16 Monate man hat natürlich auch gelernt
die nuklearen Drohungen Russlands besser
zu lesen ja also während am Anfang
sozusagen da sehr viel Unsicherheit war
weil sich keiner in so einer Situation
jemals gefunden hat
ist jetzt keine absolute Sicherheit aber
man hat gelernt sozusagen das besser zu
lesen und was im Bundeskanzler anbelangt
glaube ich dass er irgendwann mal
realisiert hat das Wladimir Putin halt
nicht diese off fremd haben will also
sozusagen die Situation wo man sagt der
weiß dass er sich verrannt hat ist jetzt
gilt es nur noch dieses Angebot zu
finden
kommt jetzt zu realisieren der Mann will
keine Rampe der will diesen Krieg jetzt
erstmal fortführen und Deutschland wird
ihm keine Rampe bieten können und das
erklärt glaube ich sozusagen dass die
Zögerlichkeit jetzt ein bisschen
zurückgenommen worden ist und wie die
Entscheidungen ein bisschen sozusagen
schneller geworden ist die Zögerlichkeit
von der beiden Administration ich glaube
das war ganz ganz stark auch natürlich
bei der Frage wann wann werden die
Russen zumutlerwaffen so und das hat
lange Zeit gedauert bis man sozusagen
dieses Szenario mit den nuklearen
Drohungen und was dann sozusagen real
passiert nämlich nichts bis man das
einigermaßen einordnen konnte und dann
eine gewisse Handlungssicherheit
gefunden
gefährliches Spiel aber da greift
das Verhältnis USA China an der Stelle
weil keiner hat das Interesse und da
greift das da im Grunde eine
Auseinandersetzung um Taiwan dann zu
einer tatsächlichen
selber signalisiert haben zunächst
einmal bei der UN-Generalversammlung der
chinesische Außenminister der indische
dass sie einen Einsatz von Seiten nicht
tolerieren werden und dann geht's nach
Bali zu G20 glaube ich warte und da
zeichnen halt im Prinzip die beiden
Antagonisten USA und China ein
gemeinsames Dokument wo der Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen
dass wir bisher verstanden haben gerne
die Hände frei gehabt hätte für die
Auseinandersetzung mit China über Taiwan
und sich ja eigentlich wünscht dass die
Europäer irgendwann souverän genug sind
und kräftig genug um sich um Europa zu
kümmern an der Stelle
in dieser Politik an dieser Idee wird
sich in Washington nichts verändert
haben bestimmt nicht die gesamte Ukraine
Situation wird von Washington aus dem
Aspekte es kommt der Konfrontation mit
China gelesen das von vornherein ja und
ich meine die die Plan A aber ja sich
mit Putin zu verständigen das war der
gesamte amerikanische Diplomatie 21 lief
ja da auch hinaus irgendwie einen Weg zu
finden damit man sich auf China kommt
von konzentrieren kann also Putin quasi
in das Diplom in die diplomatisch
Umarmung zu nehmen damit ich China
alleine
zu Entspannung zu kommen
neutralisiert keine zu Neutralität
ich brauche keinen Auto oder Flugzeug
ich brauche Munition damit klar
Gelegenheit hat das komplette
ukrainische Parlament hat gestanden ist
da geblieben für demok Debatten damit
hat Putin überhaupt nicht gerechnet
losgelöst davon dass die NATO wächst und
die europäische
jetzt das neue Interesse Washingtons
dann ist jetzt das Interesse Washingtons
Russland nennenswert zu schwächen ja
bestimmt ja ich meine EU keine bietet
eben dazu die Gelegenheit die praktisch
selbstmörderische Tendenz des Budgets
ist eine historische Möglichkeit mit der
die Amerikaner nicht gerechnet haben und
und es wäre aber fahrlässig ihrerseits
sind sie spielen das große Spiel es ist
tatsächlich ein riesen Wagnis dass sie
eingegangen sind in diesem Moment wo sie
gesagt haben okay die Geschichte liefert
uns diese Möglichkeit Russland
entscheiden zu sprechen wenn nicht zu
brechen
in oder warteterweise und die die die
Ukrainer sind anders und Hammer und das
müssen darauf müssen wir uns einlassen
und es ist ein Riese im Ungeheuer das
ganze später bei weil man nicht wusste
wie es mit der atomband aussieht
und sie sparen es weiter
davon sollte man sich sollte man nicht
verkleinlichen also dass das Risiko dass
sie eingegangen sind ist enorm die Frage
ist ob sie das durchhalten kann jetzt
mittlerweile zu Hause oder ob das
amerikanische Publikum gewisser Weise in
die ja einfach das Problem ist zu alt
und so langweilig und man möchte sich
fortbewegen
hier sind China
die große Auseinandersetzung von
Mohammed Ali Kissinger konnte man hören
100 ist er gerade geworden und hatte den
Gedanken in den Raum gebracht ich mache
es ganz kurz dass die Ukraine
tatsächlich die besetzten Gebiete 24.02
akzeptieren und hergeben und dafür in
die Natur aufgegeben aufgenommen werden
ist das in ihren Augen also damit hat er
erstmal beide Seiten quasi typiert es
ist für jeden eigentlich für beide
Seiten nicht annehmbar aber wäre das ein
eine Brücke über die sie gingen um bei
der Brücke von Katsch zu bleiben das
entscheide ich ja nicht also
entscheidende die Verhandlungspartner
aber das ist ja so aber insofern dass da
kann ich auch nicht vorgreifen aber ich
glaube dass die die Ziele der Ukraine
das gesamte Gebiet zurückzuerobern auch
die Krim zurückzuholen dass die
unrealistisch sind und das ist besser
wäre wenn man an der Stelle bereit wäre
Kompromisse zu machen denn bei diesem
Krieg sterben jeden Tag Menschen jeden
Tag sie sollen sich verteidigen dürfen
natürlich aber es ist noch sehr oft mal
die Realität sehen jeden Tag Menschen
und die sind auch viele Menschen in der
Ukraine die nicht freiwillig in diesem
Krieg kämpfen sondern die zum kriegst du
Wehrdienst verpflichtet werden
mit Menschen so ernsthaft zu glauben
dass man dann das Land kennt das ist
aber wirklich eine sehr enger Sichtweise
aus Berlin
hören
dass es Flugabwehrwaffen gibt der ist
meisten
Aktion kann sich ganz eindeutig für
entsprechendes Waffen international
ausgeschlossen ist nicht richtig
verstanden aber ich glaube
Flugabwehr sollte die Ukraine unbedingt
nach wie vor der Auffassung das ist
richtig wäre zu deeskalieren und das
eine weitere Auffassung Spirale
von Flugabwehrraketen gesprochen aber
wir reden jetzt aber über Kampfjets
sie sollen direkt weiter eskaliert mit
all den furchtbaren Konsequenzen sie das
haben möchte
das sagen wir machen mal einen Punkt
weil ich wollte nur sagen zu der NATO
Mitgliedschaft nein wir müssen jetzt
tatsächlich keine Chance so sorry gut
Kolle
entschuldigung das ist jetzt ein harter
Schnitt und ein harter Eingriff aber nur
in das nur in der sendegeschehen vielen
Dank nach Goslar logischerweise vielen
Dank hier der Runde für alles was wir
verstanden haben und ich gebe sofort und
in Farbe zu Markus Lanz der heute unter
anderem mit dem kreativ zu Gast sind sie
kommen gut durch die Woche wir sehen uns
in der nächsten wieder 22:15 Uhr
gleichstellig gleiche Welle vielen Dank
danke schön
[Musik]